foreign
[Music]
can officially fly we officially have
our Superman and Lois Clark Kent and
Lois Lane have been cast as David Corn
sweat and Rachel bras Dehan officially
before we get into it I have a lot to
say please do like subscribe leave a
comment hit that notification Bell and
speaking of Superman his compatriot
Batman we have a bat verse shirt over
its shop zeroedition.com and speaking of
announcements we will be at Comic-Con
where I thought this was going to
announce more details to come on that
but if you're a fan of the rejects head
on down to San Diego Comic-Con for our
first San Diego panel ever but let's get
into it I can't I can't draw this out I
just want to talk about it I'm so
excited all right getting into David
Corn sweat as Superman I think this
follows in the noble tradition of
Christopher Reeve of Brandon Routh of
even Henry Cavill in that it is a mostly
unknown yes Christopher Reeve had worked
before yes Henry Cavill had some great
credits and yes Brandon Routh had been
someone people wanted because of the
look but largely they were unknowns to
the overall population in a really
beautiful way because I think what makes
Superman work is you see yourself in him
and that's what humanizes him this is an
alien this is a god this is an
all-powerful entity but you need to
connect with Superman and I think an
unknown is the best way to do that
because when you're associating a lot of
his work you're going to go oh I think
of him as blank or oh this is familiar
to me because of this experience or oh
this and this blank slates are a
beautiful open source of man that's
Superman this is iconically Superman
James Gunn even said I completely relate
to Superman because he's everything I am
he's somebody who is an outsider who
feels like an alien but also the
ultimate Insider because he's beeping
Superman and that's kind of like I feel
like this is our director and writer
connecting to Superman and I think if
you've got too much baggage if you've
got too much past tense Association
you're not going to feel that with a
character I really love Nicholas Holt I
really was actually honestly gunning for
Nicholas Holt as Superman because I like
the guy and because he's been almost
Batman he's been almost Superman it's
just kind of like Henry Cavill Henry
Cavill was almost James Bond like he's
almost been a lot so I was really
pulling for him but I honestly I'll
totally own I would have saw him as the
war boy from Mad Max I would have
thought of him as not necessarily beast
but certain other roles of his and I
would have thought of that the whole
time David kornspot I don't know and I
love that and it's a beautiful tradition
of what Superman is this I think is
going to connect us to Superman this I
think is the right casting call the guy
looks like him I'm very excited about it
so this is uh an Aces win for me and I
love James Gunn's casting let's go over
to Rachel Brosnahan now Rachel Brosnahan
as Lois Lane is I think pitch perfect
because there's a certain
intellectualism that I want Lois Lane to
always have and I think the way she
handles Amy Sherman palladino's dialogue
is exactly that there's a linguistic
ability that when you're a Pulitzer
prize-winning writer you probably have
you can handle language and Amy Sherman
Palladino writes like Aaron Sorkin she
writes and I am a pantaner almost she's
got this Shakespearean flavor that is so
hard to deliver that is so hard to wrap
your brain and mouth around that she
just does and does so well that I
honestly think the beauty of the simple
boy from Kansas in Smallville juxtaposed
with the PowerHouse that is Rachel
brosnahan's City girl from Metropolis is
going to sing I also think of Rachel
Brosnahan as a little older than what I
see David Corn spit as and I kind of
like that dynamic because there's a more
authoritative Lois Lane to Superman
being this innocent boy scout I think
that juxtaposition is also going to
really tie in this character and I think
that when I think of Rachel Brosnahan
the first thing I think is capable than
I think intelligent then I think well
spoken all things I would describe Lois
Lane as I think Lois Lane is maybe the
most important casting in the DCU
because you've got expectations of
Batman you've got expectations of
Superman but Superman doesn't work
without Lois because that's the anchor
to his Humanity in so many ways along
with Jimmy along with the The Daily
Planet but I think of the love that
Superman has for Lois that when he is
pushed up against the wall he always has
that when he's doubting himself for
doubting Humanity he always has Lois so
Lois I feel like is this sleeper Ace in
the whole of casting and I think Rachel
Brosnan is really going to embody that I
think it was really important now if you
look at the other names we had here we
had Thomas Brittany and Nicholas Holt I
mentioned Nicholas Holt already I didn't
know Tom Brittany that well Emma McKay
and Phoebe dynaver I did not know it all
but their look was so good I've seen a
little bit of mmk's work but I don't
know their work that well but I think
that when you look at all of this
casting you've got this beautiful
innocence in all four of them in their
own way I know that James Gunn had said
he wanted Superman be someone that you
want to hug someone that's approachable
I think all three of these names
absolutely represent that but I think
with Emma McKay Phoebe and Rachel
Brosnahan those are all very strong
well-spoken capable actresses that are
leading ladies I want Lois Lane to be a
leading role in this film to the point
where I want scenes where it's like man
Superman's also here and I think that's
what we're gonna get with Rachel
Brosnahan so both of these castings I
think are absolutely genius I'm excited
dive into more as soon as we have any
examples but let's kick it over to Lex
Lex Luthor is a bit of an unknown
because this might be
might be I'm going to stress that might
be one of the skarsgards that has been
the rumor a lot of the rumors have come
true David Corn sweat has been rumored
for months Rachel Brosnahan had been
rumored for a month so clearly the leaks
are coming from somewhere that's that's
credible the rumor is Bill Skarsgard is
up against his own brother Alexander
Skarsgard for the role of Lex Luthor I
love this because one it mirrors the
Thor uh Hemsworth situation where Liam
Hemsworth was basically up for it until
Chris Hemsworth came back and then it
worked out that Chris Hemsworth got the
role Brothers at odds for superhero
Legacy is it's a very interesting thing
but with Lex Luthor I could see both of
them being cold and calculating but
impossibly likable which is Lex Luthor
uh John and I have been watching all the
DC Animated Universe films all of them
in all the universes and one thing we're
both enjoying is how fascinatingly
endearing Lex Luthor is that's the
skarsgards even as Pennywise Bill
Skarsgard is like why do I want to know
more about him you shouldn't he's
terrifying and Alexander Skarsgard
always has that energy the Northman is
one of the most slept on movies I think
in the last five years because this
brutal Viking of pure violence is so
captivating and interesting and that's
what he always plays whether he's Tarzan
whether he's like a rom-com lead or
whether he's literally a Viking Warrior
he is always fascinating so both bill or
Alexander I could either see and
personally I see a bit of a bigger Lex
Luthor I've always seen him as kind of a
physically capable man I'd love to see
either Bill get jacked like his brother
or Alexander Skarsgard just says Jack
I'd also love uh Alex playing Alex just
for fun Linguistics and Alexander
Skarsgard as Lex Luthor is a good time
so either Skarsgard would make me very
happy I love the playfulness of Brothers
going against each other they also seem
like they really like trust love and
respect each other their dad stellen
Skarsgard also a big actor I don't feel
like they'll be like problems at
Thanksgiving if one of them gets cast
and the other doesn't I feel like
they're a loving family so I think
skarsgards for this are absolutely
delightful I hope that rumor is true
that has not been confirmed James Gunn
has only confirmed David Corn sweat and
Rachel Brosnahan he has not even
mentioned Lex Luthor but now that that's
been announced I imagine this would come
out any day now so I'm wondering if DC
slash Warner Brothers does end up at
Comic-Con they have not announced
whether or not they will we've had a
number of Studios Marvel Studios Netflix
I believe Universal all say no no we're
not going to San Diego Comic-Con that
doesn't mean Marvel Comics does isn't
there that doesn't mean necessarily
certain other elements then the film
side aren't going to be there but dcwb
as of filming this have not announced I
would love to see David Corn sweat
Rachel Brosnahan and a Skarsgard come
out on stage and announce this movie I
would love to see a presentation with
them I think fan installations are
allowed even with the SAG strike so I
think as long as it's not technically
pressed they would be allowed to present
it in a panel setting with all the
hijinks going on with the strike I
support the writer strike I support a
sag strike if it happens as of filming
this the SAG strike hasn't officially
gone through but I would love to see
these three gets Go on stage with James
Gunn and hopefully Peter saffron and
really make a big to do out of this
whole thing but we've got our Superman
in lowest Lane so I wanted to bring all
this data to you guys now this is a
koi's comic corner so I'm not going to
leave you without some comic
recommendations get after Superman a man
for all seasons get after All-Star
Superman and in my opinion get after
Superman up in the sky now the reason I
picked those Superman and man for all
seasons is a book that feels very
beautifully hopeful for Humanity it
feels very available it feels like if
you've never read a comic before you can
be like man this guy I love that book
The Art is gorgeous the writing is great
All-Star Superman I've raved about James
Gunn's talked about it we're just gonna
assume that's like in pen that's just
there so you can also read that one and
then Superman up in the sky is from Tom
King Tom King is writing the movie as
well as has already written the comic of
woman of tomorrow which is the Supergirl
movie I know James Gunn is a fan of Tom
King I'm a huge fan of Tom King I think
his Superman is modern in a way that
doesn't keep you stuck in that 60s
Superman but it's still that boy scout
it's still a man that's always going to
do what's right but what I love about up
in the sky is it's an anthology series
for the most part there's like a one or
two issue Arc but a lot of them you can
just pick up by themselves and you have
no continuity to tie to you you can
literally just read this run and not
have to worry about any other thing so
approachability is really important when
introducing people to Comics I really
think up in the sky is going to be your
cup of tea if you've never read a comic
it's modern but still classic and it's
written by a great DC writer who's also
wielding the movie so Superman Man For
All Seasons All-Star Superman and
Superman up in the sky all very
approachable I want you guys to be able
to pick these up without continuity and
dive in and I do think these are going
to be the vibe of James Gunn Superman
all right that is going to do it for
this koi's comic Corner breaking news
Edition it was good to be back in this
koi's comic Corner chair with you
lovelies please do leave a comment below
let me know what you think of this
casting announcement please do like this
video share it wide I want to bring
comic corner back a little bit more
often but there hasn't been a lot of
news so it's it's not it's not on us we
just we didn't have any news but now
that it's back you leave a comment below
and let me know you want to see more and
what you'd like to see me cover get to
reading some Comics get to watching some
movies go hug your family do what
Superman would do which is always not
killing people in a very crowded City
all right much love we'll see you soon
[Music]